demain à versailles les grandes eaux
musicales une opération très
particulière à destination du public
pour permettre à ce site historique
s'est durement touchée par la tempête de
revivre reportages rares dalmaz michel
vasseur bassa de l'atome
l'un des favoris du parcours écrit par
louis xiv qui adorait ses jardins et
tout leur plaisir le dimanche les eaux
musicales au nord l'oeuvre du souverain
avec des morceaux composés pour la cour
le fief du roi soleil c'est aussi le
monde des arbres 10000 massacré par la
tempête de fin décembre
certains avaient été plantés par marie
antoinette un peu partout dans le parc
se distinguent fort bien la trouée
géante du chemin de l'attendre ce qui
touche la forêt touche le fameux chef
amazonien raoni il est venu spécialement
aux jardins du roi pour y planter un
arbre originaire d amérique dossiers
prioritaires de versailles la
replantation dans dix ans espère ton et
le rat masqué les cats ont enlevé le
suit qui tombait le traité acheter
nouvel arbre le transporter le planter
remettre en état le sol safina une dix
mille francs
dix mille arbres à 10000 francs 100
millions assumés par l'état le mécénat
américains surtout mais aussi les
entrées du public d'où grandes eaux
musicales exceptionnelles demain samedi
un tour de clé lire la musique
s'envolent les eaux aussi que la fête
commence
si le spectacle en surface est étonnant
la cuisine se terrait ne l'est pas moins
les douze sans jets d'eau sont alimentés
par un réseau louis 14e plomb et joints
de cuir
d'où quelques faiblesses sauf pour les
tuyaux deux dernières se comptent en
pire quand même
et
cinquante mille entrées les jours de
grandes eaux musicales demain le roi
soleil n'aura même pas besoin de son
pouvoir absolu pour exiger la foule
patrimoine du monde
versailles blessés ne peut qu'émouvoir
le monde entier